[Music]
here's the thing i like you
i know your diagnosis complicates things
but i don't care i mean
do you like me yes i do even though i
don't have
cancer make your move romeo
most teenagers feel like they're
invincible not the superman kind of
invincible
the kind of invincible that tricks you
into thinking tomorrow might be a better
day to start chasing your dreams
we've been through this just breeze you
are my best friend so you are morally
obligated to say nice things to me
everybody else out there is not my best
friend if everyone else doesn't like it
then
they're idiots and while there's a lot
that i don't know at my age what i do
know is this
we all have limited time tell me
something you never told before before i
walk through the door i
adore you i adore you i do how are you
i'm off chemo is it because it worked or
i do what you're facing
is scary but you get to decide what
matters most now
never give up a front door are you
writing a song
hello i was thinking might be cool if we
did something that was just ours
zack have you looked on youtube you have
20 000 views
you should be happy i thought this is
what you wanted it doesn't really matter
what i want because it's not going to
happen
it's not there stop i have nothing to
give you no rings no future nothing
there's so much in there that the world
needs to hear what are you gonna do with
it
[Music]
this is insane just breathe
[Music]
[Music]
in the end i just want to make people
happy i zachary zobiak i'm asking you
for as long as i can
because what some people take for
granted others are fighting for and
believe me
i'm a fighter
[Music]
you